that woman with seven DUIs on her record
telling a judge she'd rather be behind
bars than in a sober living facility and
away from her kids 8 news now
investigator David charns the only
reporter there Mary and Reyes
self-terminated her DUI program
essentially sending her to prison that's
something she says she wanted Marion
Reyes 35 year old Marion Reyes appearing
before a judge for the first time since
her arrest nearly two weeks ago
to go to prison I wanted to get the
student over with Reyes speaking with
the eight news now investigators last
week has seven DUI arrests on her record
she initially avoided prison as part of
a felony DUI program putting her instead
in sober living but she says she got two
write-ups while there a judge sending
her to jail for two days for punishment
[Music]
is the problem for me while being booked
earlier this month Reyes says the jail
removed her alcohol monitoring bracelet
and then failed to put it back on her
when they released her there was no
mention of the bracelet during the quick
hearing Tuesday a judge agreeing to
remove Reyes from sober living and as
part of that plea deal she already had
agreed to prison time should the program
not work out why do you want to just go
to prison because have teenage kids
and every little detail that I do is
being put on the media
and is being made out to be a hundred
times worse than it is
exactly when she could go to prison or
what happens next we don't know it's up
to another judge who will hear this case
next week at the Regional Justice Center
in downtown Las Vegas I'm David charns 8
News Now as David mentioned in this case
of seven DUIs there's one step left
we'll be sure to keep you posted on what
the judge determines in terms of prison
time in the coming weeks